It's kind of funny cause
after the elections I was at this press
conference for Black Youth vote and I
was talking about all the work that we
did with our campaign powerboat and
they'll,
so this article came out with in the
Associated Press and basically I had
said a statement that's like,
well,
and this really happened,
you know,
after the elections,
Fox News and,
and white people.
I just knew we're like,
yeah this is great.
You know,
racism is over now that we have a black
president.
And it's like,
first of all,
your statement in of itself shows that
racism isn't dead because if it was you
wouldn't acknowledge that he was black
in the first place.
Um,
and so it gotten like 200 different
papers,
like randomly who's like really strange.
But I got things like face,
like,
like these blogs,
these conservative bloggers like
attacking me.
And that was the first time it was like,
Whoa,
like,
you know,
googling my name,
finding images and putting it on blogs
so they could talk stuff about me and
that with like crazy to me.
But
it was like they were upset cause I had
the audacity to say that no,
racism isn't dead.
And even though we Obama won,
we still have to work.
Like it's not just going to be up to
Obama.
He's not a superhero.
He is a super motivator.
And he is motivated our generation to
say,
why not?
Why not create change?
Why not be the best generation we can
be?
Why not,
you know,
stand up for what we believe in.
Why not just be more successful?
Why not just try harder?
Why not just advocate?
Why not just go into Congress and to
Capitol Hill and lobby our
congresspeople?
It's not that hard.
And he's done all that.
But like I said,
he's not a superhero.
And so it was funny to me because they
were mad that I said racism isn't dead.
But it was like in their statements,
they were racist to like,
one was like niggers are still whining
and,
um,
you know,
you're only 23,
what do you know about racism or all
these different things?
And
I just,
it's very interesting to me.
So I think,
uh,
even with Obama in office,
we have a long road ahead of people of
having to just build intercultural
politics and intercultural communication
that
is more uplifting and uniting.
And I think that as a coalition energy
action coalition has been working
really,
really hard to try and develop that as a
goal,
as a true strategic goal.